[Music]
[Applause]
Jason Garrett football night America and
uh their coverage of the divisional
playoffs begins Saturday at three
Eastern football night in America from
Kansas City as the Chiefs host
Jacksonville good to talk to you again
Jason which opening do you think is the
best right now
oh
um great question I think it depends on
the coach I'd say Sean Payton
yeah I think the things that that Sean
will value uh are things that a lot of
people value and and I think maybe he
has some more
um
uh options than most
uh I think more than anything else he
wants a structure and an organization
where he has clout and he has
um you know a decision-making power that
you know makes everything kind of stop
with him
uh uh and and so I think that's probably
that's probably line one for him uh
resources in the organization to make
decisions
uh to go get players and having a big
budget I think that's a big thing and
and I think the other part of it is the
quarterback situation
um you know Sean was very fortunate in
in New Orleans to have a Hall of Fame
quarterback and Drew Brees and they were
tremendous collaboration
but but I think he he recognized that it
was harder his last year when Drew Brees
wasn't there so having a planet
quarterback whether the guy's in place
or whether there's no one's in place so
he can go get a guy to be his next Drew
Brees I think those are probably the
biggest factors for him okay taking all
of that into consideration which team
fits that criteria
um two two ways to go Sean has to Sean
has to decide what his feelings are
about Russell Wilson and Kyler Murray
does does he see those guys as people he
wants to work with obviously both have
been very accomplished players Russell
Wilson it's a nine-time pro bowler and
obviously it wasn't his best year in
Denver this past year but he's had a ton
of success you know he could potentially
be a Hall of Fame quarterback so does
Sean see him as someone he can kind of
get right and get playing to the level
that he played at before uh certainly
the the the the people in Denver have an
immense amount of resources the Walmart
family and all of that uh Denver's a
great place to live it's a great history
and tradition in that organization so uh
you know George Payton who's the general
manager there fantastic person so you
know I that could be attractive to him
uh again what's his feeling on Kyler
Murray uh there's a commitment in
Arizona to Kyler Murray for a long time
how does that work out I I gotta believe
that you know he would have have a lot
of say in what goes on there going
forward but then Carolina you know
there's a lot of money there in Carolina
there is no established quarterback
maybe that's a better way to go where
you don't have a guide you can kind of
clean the Slate so you know we can argue
them 100 different ways I think as much
as anything else when he's traveling the
country visiting with people it's going
to be a gut instinct and a gut feel for
what he thinks is the best environment
take us through the interviewing process
when you got the Cowboys job
so when you get off the plane
then what happens like take us through
the steps of how many interviews
how many people are you selling yourself
to Jerry Jones my philosophy of the
franchise this is what I see this is the
you know the crystal ball
do you want the real story Dan yeah yeah
yeah
it's a really good story it's a long
story
um you know I was coaching with the
Miami Dolphins at the time I just
finished playing and then Nick Saban
became the head coach there and uh and
so I was a quarterback with the dolphins
my last year for the last part of the
season and a couple weeks later I became
their quarterback coach
and I did that for a couple years then
Coach Saban Went to went to Alabama
and uh Cam Cameron was hired as the
Dolphins head coach
and I wasn't going to be there but I was
still with them but I was under contract
so I was going to kind of see what the
potential options were maybe in college
football
and just kind of play it out a little
bit so I go to the
I go to the Senior Bowl wearing my Miami
Dolphins gear and and Coach Parcells
retires from the Cowboys
uh on Monday of that week so I'm at the
Senior Bowl on Tuesday and I'm at
practice and I get a phone call and uh
it's uh you know some people from the
Dolphins saying that the Cowboys want to
visit with me about this job and uh you
know Wayne hizanga was the owner of the
of the Dolphins at the time and he and
Jerry Jones obviously have a
relationship and and they talked and uh
Jerry had explained to him that you know
I had been a player for the Cowboys for
eight years and that had been a big part
of my life before and he'd love to have
a visit with me even though I was under
contract and
so the the deal was you have until 12
noon on Thursday you have this window to
talk and figure something out
so I kind of get all my stuff together
and I leave early Wednesday morning to
to go from Mobile Alabama to Dallas
and it was kind of a surreal experience
I think the flight was was literally at
six A.M
and and I get to the airport early and
there had been a WWE event in Mobile the
night before so so I'm I'm on this
little plane uh from Mobile to Dallas
with all these professional wrestlers
and uh
so I'm in line with these guys I'm like
who are you guys oh yeah we had this big
event the night before and you know
these CL I mean there were like 10 of
them you know men and women it was like
the crazy you know it was dark and Misty
out I'm like where am I right now what
am I doing and uh so anyway I got my
Dolphins gear on and I'm heading to
Dallas and
I get there early I get there like eight
o'clock in the morning and I go over to
Valley Ranch the old facility and and uh
I just spent the day with Jerry and
Steven and uh and we just talked all
about kind of what the idea would be now
you got to remember that
the Cowboys didn't have a head coach so
it was you know I'm two years into
coaching so you know what is this for is
this for the head coach is this for a
coordinator position you know why are we
talking so we kind of explained
all of that and and you know what my
philosophy would be and how I would
build a program and and everything and
so it went on all day long and I've
known Jerry for years
and Stephen for years but we just spent
a lot of time together uh that day and
it ended up at like two o'clock in the
morning at this place Al bernay's in
Dallas which is kind of this famous
steak place in the back just listening
to uh Stephen and Jerry and us having a
great conversation and and when you when
you play it back I'd probably gotten up
at three o'clock in the morning in
Mobile and that was about two o'clock so
I've been up for about 23 straight hours
talking philosophy and were you offered
a job at this Steakhouse
what's that were you offered the job at
the steakhouse
no uh Stephen told me later the stamina
that I had that day was really
impressive to Jerry
when did they offer you the job
uh I can't remember you know we talked
about it the next day and and and and
eventually we said hey don't leave we're
gonna figure something out here wow and
uh and so before 12 noon on Thursday
which was the deadline we decided that I
was going to stay in Dallas in some
capacity
did you ever think that maybe it was too
much for you too soon after your playing
career with not having a long coaching
history
well it certainly happened fast there's
no question about that
um but but I had been in football for a
long time and I was fortunate to be
around really good people and eventually
I was named the offensive coordinator
and you rely on your experiences with
North Turner and Ernie zampizi and Sean
Payton and John Gruden and and a lot of
those guys that I was fortunate to be
around and uh you know you dive in you
know when you get when you've got your
first job at ESPN you probably weren't
ready you dive in you figure it out you
make your mistakes you keep going and
that's what we did
we're talking to Jason Garrett football
night in America would you rather have a
cocky quarterback or a confident
quarterback
um
I think in order to be great you have to
you have to be on the edge of Cockiness
I think cocky matters as long as cocky
doesn't mean that you're not willing to
go through the steps to prepare the
right way
you know
um I think that's an important thing Joe
burrow
tows the line
yeah love them
he's got he's got Swagger that's his
personality that's who he is uh he
clearly works at it he clearly cares
about it he clearly respects the process
and who he's going against but he's got
a little he's got a little Edge to him
and uh he's got some fantastic outfits
he likes to express himself that way but
but you know he when he gets in that
huddle he's in charge and I think that's
what's most important we talked to Tony
Dungy yesterday and he said after the
third Miss by the Cowboys kicker he
would have benched him and then just
gone for two after that
what do you think of that philosophy
what would you have done in that
situation well you know I think it was
probably easier for them to stick with
him because the game was out of hand
um you know my instinct and probably I'm
biased towards Brett Maher because he
was a really good kicker for us yeah I
probably would have stuck with him and
kept giving him chances knowing that he
was had to kick his way out of it but
Tony makes a great point you know if
that game is close and it's you know
24-24 you know what do you do there yes
and those become harder decisions you
ever yelled at a kicker
uh I don't think I ever yelled at a
kicker we don't yell at kickers too we
put our arms around kickers don't we we
we we treat them differently than we do
anybody else right yeah it's it's
interesting that there's
uh a fragility to Kickers that you know
kind of comes with
the with the position so uh you treat
them with kid gloves have you seen uh
enough of Trevor Lawrence does he enter
into that picture with Justin Herbert or
Joe burrow or you know these younger
quarterbacks is he there yet I don't
think he's there yet but boy he's on his
way and uh you know to talk about a
great marriage between him and Doug
Peterson and that offensive staff you
see marked improvement in him over the
course of the year and you know as much
as anything else you know a couple
things you're always trying to teach
your quarterbacks as quick and decisive
you know go back make your decisions get
the ball out of your hand I think that's
such an important trait for guys and uh
it goes back to a little bit what we're
talking about confidence and Cockiness
and preparation all of that gets
manifested in those qualities he's quick
he's decisive he's getting it out of his
hand and it really looks like a
different quarterback the last half of
this year how's TV treating you
it's been great I've I've really enjoyed
it you know you know the people at NBC
or first class and
you know what's been fun about it for me
Dan is I I go in knowing that I don't
know how to do this and you try to have
a humility about that but you're also
going to dive in and try to get it done
and they've been so good in being
supportive and positive with me but also
very instructive which I've appreciated
I actually said that to him I said the
only thing I'm going to be mad at you is
if you don't tell me yeah I'm coachable
just tell me if it's not good just tell
me and I'll try to figure it out and
make it better the next time and
everybody at NBC has been great in that
regard how close did you come to taking
the Stanford job
you know it's an intriguing place it
really is I've always had great
admiration for it and that's why I went
out there and visited with them uh you
know you get a chance to talk to uh
Andrew Luck and Condoleezza Rice and
Bruce Dunleavy and Bernard Muir Bernard
Muir is the A.D at Stanford and Bruce
dunleave is a distinguished Alum and
you're talking about being the head
coach out there it was a really fun
experience stimulating experience but
you know at the end of it the college
landscape is changing and uh you know
you embrace the standards at a place
like Stanford you want to coach those
kinds of kids who are so driven
but with transfer portal and nil and a
lot of the other factors it might be
hard to win an environment like that so
I was thankful for the opportunity but
I'm glad I did what I did yeah who would
have thought that the NFL would be
simpler than college football but it's
the case isn't it crazy yeah yeah and
only getting crazier here until they
understand what nil is uh you know I'm
really I'm really hoping they somehow
put some curves on these things and I
don't know how they do it
um you know I think it's good nil is a
good thing in concept but hopefully it
gets used the right way to benefit the
kids and not to
you know uh too much uh recruiting of
high school kids and and and transfers
uh is a Bad Thing using nil so hopefully
they can get that all sorted out thanks
for sharing this story there with the
Cowboys job and uh have fun in Kansas
City great to talk to you again Jace I
always love talking to you Dan that's
Jason Garrett football night in America
it'll be football afternoon in America
they got Kansas City and the Jags
that'll uh be starting I think at three
Eastern on NBC in peacock we'll take a
break we've got our play of the day up
next